check me out I am in the iconic New York
Lego Store to check in with Lego Master
Matt Ashton who's back in Lego group's
Denmark studio is it true that you were
involved in the development of Lego
Masters I sort of helped a little bit
with formulating that but my main role
was um pet judge on the UK version and
now it's developed into a big beast of
its own so super proud of how we planted
that seed and now it's grown into
something amazing
working with the LEGO Group has now led
you to this pretty cool opportunity
where you got to work on Katy Perry's
leg address for the new holiday campaign
so tell me this were you a Katy Perry
fan before the project I'm a huge fan of
Katie so it was a Little Dream Come True
when I heard there was a possibility for
me to help out with this hi guys it's
Katie I wanted to give a special thank
you to Matt so how do you do that we
teamed up with Matt in the LEGO Group
for an exclusive look at the design
process so I was called in to co-design
this dress with Heather picciatino who's
one of Katie's fashion designers we kind
of felt that we really needed to get
Katie's personality through in the dress
Katie's Nikon the Lego brick is also an
icon so we were like right let's just
find a way to cover her in um giant Lego
bricks and I think Katie's got a real
child-like playfulness that um fits
perfectly with the messaging of this
campaign so it's been absolutely amazing
tougher part of it I'm so excited that
the dress is now on display in the New
York store right where you are Rachel
I'd really like to recommend that you
join in with some of the experiences
there's a great personalization
experience called minifigure Factory
where you can create your very own
Minifigures so go and give that a go oh
yeah Matt dun
[Music]